الى مدينه شنغهاي الصينيه التي اندلعت
فيها اليوم مظاهرات تمدد او تطالب
بالتراجع عن قيودي فيروس كرونا المشدده
التي تفرضها السلطه الصيني طبعا
الاحتجاجات توسعت الى مدن اخرى عقب حريق
اسفر عن مقتل 10 اشخاص يوم الخميس في مبنا
برموتشي عاصمه اقليم شنجان ونشر نشطون على
مواقع التواصل مقاطع مصوره تظهر مطالبات
الحشود برفع الاغلاق عن جميع انحاء
هذا منظمه عدد من الطلاب في جامعه شنخوه
بالعاصمه الصينيه بيجين وقفتنا احتجاجيه
في حرم الجامعه تمديدا بالسياسات الاغلاق
المستمره بسبب تفشي فايروس
نعم للحريه تزامنا مع استمرار السلطات
الصينيه في تطبيق اجراءات صارمه لمنع تفشي
الفيروس وسط التزايد اعداد الاصابات في
نحو احدى وثلاثين مدينه وقد اعلنت العاصمه
بيجين تسجيل اكثر من اربعه الاف حاله
اصابه جديده بالفيروس السبت معضمها لا
تحملوا اعراض المرض
مبين مراسله الجزيره شيماء جويلي شيماء
شيماء ربما تكون الصين الان من الدول
القليله لم تكن الوحيده في العالم التي
تمارس الاغلاق ما الاسباب التي تعطيها
بيوجين لهذا الاغلاق رغم هذا التمالم والا
الواضح غير المسبوق من هذه الاجراءات
القليله او ربما الوحيده في العالم التي
منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات منذ ظهور الوباء لم
يتم رفع الاغلاق الحدود وقدود السفر
لفتح حدودها امام السياحه الدوليه بالتالي
الاجراءات الان تتشدد اكثر والصمود جديده
مع تدني درجه الحراره والدخول فصل الشتاء
خاصه
الشماليه والشرقيه والغربيه الاحتجاجات
اليوم في العاصمه الصناعيه بجان تحديدا
وقفه طلابيه عدد من الطلبه وصل عددهم 300
طالب بجامعه احدى اكبر واعرف الجامعات
بالعاصمه الصينيه ينادون بمزيد من الحريه
برفع الاغلاقات التي تمنعهم حتى من العوده
الى منازل والبقاء في المبيدات وفي الحرم
الجامعه طبعا هذه الاحتجاجات لم تبدا من
بيجنن ايضا شهدت مدينه شنغهاي كبرى المدن
الاقتصاديه هنا في الصين واقفه تضامنا
المع ضحايا الحريق الذي شهده مبنا في
مدينه ارموتشي حاضره مقاطعه شين جان غربيه
البلاد ذات الاغلبيه المسلمه هذا الحريق
في وقت متاخر من ليله الجمعه اودى بحياه
10 اشخاص وهنالك
مطالبات من رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لتنفيذي تحقيقا مستقل من قبل السلطات
الصينيه لاسباب وفاه هؤلاء السكان في هذه
الشقق التي شهدت الحريق هل لم يستطيعوا
المغادره شقاقهم بسبب الاغلاق الذي تفرضه
السلطات على هذا المبنى وايضا على همم
اقليم الشنجان بالكامل الذي يشهد اغلاقا
منذ نحو مئه يوم هو واقليم ايضا الذي يشهد
اغلاقا منذ نحو مئه يوم ثلاثه اشهر من
الاغلاقات المتتاليه ليس هناك السقف
الزمني محدد لهذه الاغلاقات شاهدنا ايضا
احتجاجات خلال الاسبوع الماضي تحديدا في
مدينه
وسط الصين هذه المدينه التي تضم اكبر
مصانع اجهزه ايفون التي تصدر الى جميع
انحاء العالم لذلك يطلق على هذه المدينه
اسم ايفون سيتي
تحديدا في مصنع
اجهزه الايفون عمال العرب من المصنع
مشتركين من الاغلاقات المتكرره
على البقاء في خطوط الانتاج للعمل نهارا
والمبيت ليلا هناك دون شخص زماني وحدد
اشتقاقه من ظروفهم الصحيه الصعبه وايضا من
عدم تلقيهم للاجور المتفق عليه
بالاحتجاجات وصلت الى درجه التشابك وايضا
قام رجال الامن باستخدام العصي لتفريق هذه
الاحتجاجات وضرب العمال الذين استطاع عدد
كبير منهم الهروب من المصنع اذا هي
في الصين ان يكون هناك احتجاجات بالفعل
ليلى ان تكون هناك احتجاجات في مدن مختلفه
في وقت واحد تنادي السلطات لتخفيف هذه
الاجراءات قد تمتد الى احتجاجات يعني
النخبه السياسيه
تستمع لهذه الاحتجاجات والى اين يمكن ان
تصل شكرا جزيلا لك شيماء